eh what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is the Samsung Galaxy Note 4 and
right off the bat you're going to notice
it looks very similar to the Galaxy Note
3 at least in the fact that it's a large
Samsung Android phone but upon closer
inspection it is better in a lot of ways
so for messing around with it and the
quality time I got to spend with it
today I'm going to go ahead and say 90%
of the improvements to this phone are in
the hardware department and the last 10%
are in the software and I said this on
Twitter but it's kind of hard to explain
but I am now finally actually really
impressed with a piece of samsung
hardware and it's about damn time now
the software it's super familiar
essentially it's the same software we've
already seen on the galaxy s5 it's
TouchWiz on top of Android 4.4.4 kitkat
hopefully it'll get the Android L update
pretty soon and if you've handled a
Samsung Android phone before you'll know
your way around here pretty well I mean
it's literally again nearly the same as
a gs5 software but it wouldn't be a note
without having a couple extra software
tricks or two up its sleeve so one
notable one is the multitasking
improvements now you can swipe in from a
corner to make smaller windowed apps and
these windowed apps remain fully
functioning applications like they're
just a smaller version of the apps you
use already and you can move them around
and resize them the list of apps
supported by this windowing feature is
growing and you can have up to 16 of
these windows going on at the same time
not that you'll probably ever need to do
that but you can definitely be super
productive and have a whole bunch of
useful things going on for example
you're walking around the city for the
first time taking pictures with the
minimized camera but you have maps in
the background open to keep track of
where you are need stuff like that
another software trick from being a note
is working well with the improved stylus
so the s-pen has a slightly updated
design it's now actually a little bit
thinner and it has this tip that's
sensitive to many more pressure levels
so when you're writing text and their
Notes app the pressure levels will
create a different type of script and of
course it works perfectly with the note
as you'd expect I'm personally not the
biggest stylus user ever when it comes
to using my Galaxy Note but they keep
adding awesome features so you can use
it just like you'd use your finger on
the touch screen on side note if you go
with
an off-color Galaxy Note 4 like pink or
something the stylus is also pink so
that's a nice touch but outside of that
I said this is almost galaxy s5 software
with a few nifty improvements but there
is a new wide-angle selfie mode a new
shortcut to take a selfie using the new
heart rate monitor on the back and there
are a bunch of other features that I'll
have to dig through the settings to
check out but like I said the real
improvements here the real improvements
are absolutely with the hardware you can
watch all the promos and commercials and
videos you want but actually holding
this phone was the only thing that
convinced me of its premium build this
Galaxy Note 4 actually has metal now
aluminum sides and chamfered edges like
we saw on the Galaxy alpha or even the
iPhone 5s not that fake plastic looking
like metal thing on the galaxy s5 or the
note 3 but actual metal it's heavier
it's much more solid and it makes a huge
difference in the way it feels on the
hand the back of the phone is still this
softer touch faux leather look again but
they got rid of the tacky fake stitching
look and honestly seriously this is the
best looking and feeling galaxy
smartphone I think Samsung has ever made
and I'm super impressed by that
it still has a removable back so you can
add to the 32 gigs of internal storage
with a micro SD card and you can swap
out that 3220 million power battery
whenever you want
also this battery now supports a rapid
charging technology that will get you
from 0% to 50% charge in half an hour
and I got to say even the buttons are
miles better than the Galaxy s5 the
power button on the side is clicky and
tactile and oddly very satisfying to
press and the volume buttons have a nice
feeling too also made of metal and the
home button is also now a fingerprint
scanner like on the galaxy s5 but it
also is still really tactile unlike the
galaxy s5 so that's another improvement
there I just wish Samsung's fingerprint
reading technology was better and less
finicky but you know I guess that's part
of software so it's a work in progress
also the internal hardware is an upgrade
too it has a Snapdragon 805 chip
top-of-the-line and three gigs of ram oh
and if you haven't noticed it has a new
super sharp 5.7 inch quad HD Super
AMOLED display putting
at over 500 pixels per inch and
basically making it the best display on
any smartphone out right now so all of
that it's super strap display new
internal specs are awesome all that
combined with the new 16 megapixel
camera makes it a pretty sweet
viewfinder and this new camera also has
optical image stabilization which is a
first for Samsung and that should allow
for sharper photos better low-light
performance and more stable video which
is sure to keep it a top my list of best
smartphones to shoot video with now a
lot of these things that I'm spouting
out at you are just numbers like you can
say Snapdragon 805 you can say 2560 by
1440 you can say 3200 20 milliamp hours
but I will definitely be putting these
to the test for my full review this is
this is just the first impressions so
definitely subscribe if you haven't
already if you want to see the video
that it comes out sometime in October
when this phone is released where I give
my full review and all the things you
need to know about this phone but like I
said so far after just spending some
quality time with it I am very impressed
and I watched the presentation just like
you guys rolling my eyes just just
because you know Samsung presentations
can get pretty cheesy but actually
holding this metal in my hands changed
my mind
really fast so the Galaxy Note 4
continues the no tradition of baller
hardware a couple months after the
Galaxy S line comes out and these top
notch specs killer features and now
finally finally a seriously improved
build and it's about damn time Samsung
thanks for watching feel free to leave a
thumbs up if you enjoyed and I'll talk
to you guys in the next video peace